Okay.
So this morning what we're going to be dealing with is the question of the
development of the piano.
Really from the time of Mozart through Beethoven,
through Chopin,
and through list up to the modern grand piano that you see in front of us.
And we'll end with a guest performer.
A Dench lost Wartburg will be coming in about 11 o'clock and we'll be talking to
Dan at that point.
Uh,
we start with Mozart because he was the first composer to switch from the
harpsichord over to the piano.
The harpsichord was the primary instrument of course,
of the Baroque period,
as we said before,
1600 to 1750.
Now,
our first slide that we see on the screen this morning is a Dutch harpsichord,
comes in the low countries of the 17th century.
It's actually in our own collection of historical musical instruments at 17
Hillhouse avenue.
And many of the slides,
um,
that will,
we will be seeing today come from that particular collection.
So if you ever had to be sick and going over to Dui h right next to doh on this
side of the railroad tracks or the canal,
there is this splendid collection of keyboard instruments.
Uh,
you got a chance I believe,
um,
in section last time to deal with the heart to Gordon and perhaps even play the
Harpsichord and remember that produces this kind of tinkling jangling effect,
right?
So if you ever hear a tingling jangling keyboard instrument on a test,
what are you going to say about musical style?
What period does it come from?
Daniel Baroque.
Okay,
so that's a good key.
It's one of the fingerprints for a baroque music,
but young Mozart here about 1770 to 1780.
He be key came to prefer,
uh,
the,
the piano because what was the one limitation or a central limitation of the
Harpsichord?
What,
what was the problem and the essence with the Harpsichord.
A Nice and loud,
Kristin,
isn't it?
I can hardly see back there.
Kristen.
Nice and loud.
No dynamics.
Okay.
Basically you get one dynamic level.
Yeah.
You can throw some levers and maybe bring some more string strings in,
but it's cumbersome.
You can't shade or a scale,
you can't,
we reach for a climax.
It's not only dynamics,
it's shading.
That's also very important there.
So people began to switch over to this thing called the piano forte.
Originally it was all one word,
piano,
Forte,
the loud soft or the soft loud piano forte,
so that there could be gradations of,
of sound.
And this was an instrument invented in Florence around 1700.
Actually,
we know the name of the person that did it.
Bartolomeo Krista foray.
I didn't put that up on the board.
Uh,
but uh,
that's what happened in Florence around 1700 and it took it off 50 years or so
before this to kind of catch on this invention to catch on and gradually replace
the Harpsichord.
But notice that when we went and when we have our first pianos,
that they look virtually identical to the Harpsichord.
Here is a Harpsichord from our collection.
Here is a piano for,
of the storage.
That Mozart would have played about 1770.
So it's not that much bigger,
right?
Go back and forth quickly.
Uh,
if you would,
Jacob.
There's the Harpsichord and there's the piano.
And as said,
Mozart was the first co significant composer to switch from the Harpsichord to
the piano.
Mozart,
of course,
came from the city of Salzburg,
Austria.
Uh,
and he was an employee is sort of disgruntled employee of the Archbishop of
Salzburg.
He referred to the archbishop is the arch Boobie.
Uh,
and Mozart is thought to be a composer who worked at the piano.
And indeed,
uh,
so was Joseph Haydn Mozart,
a contemporary and dear,
dear friend,
it's Mozart at first called Haydn Papa Haydn.
Uh,
so let's go on to two slides here.
We've got a couple to skip and here is Haydn.
He's composing,
thinking things through at a keyboard.
And here is Mozart,
uh,
working at a keyboard,
but Mozart actually didn't compose at a keyboard.
What,
why,
why these then seated at a keyboard to show that he's a musician,
you need an icon to associated through associated with when Mozart composed,
you know where he did most of his composing.
Some of it had a billiard table,
but most of it in bed.
His sister tells us that in his wife tells us that he would get up in the
morning,
maybe just stay in bed and he had this kind of desk with ink trays and sand and
stuff.
Go block the paper and he would work in bed from about seven till 10 in the
morning.
He didn't need a pin.
He heard it all,
all in his hit.
In any event,
1781,
Mozart has had it with the arch booby of Salzburg.
He breaks free of him.
And establishing establishes himself as a freelance musician in the city of
Vienna.
This was kind of a risky gambit to be a freelance musician.
Um,
we have to freelance musicians in our midst today,
Santana and Jacob.
Um,
how is it Centena being a freelance musician?
Busy.
What do you have to do?
Run around to different gigs,
right?
Trying to,
to patch together a living as best you can until you work your way up to a more
secure position.
Same thing I'm sure with,
with Jacob.
Well,
what did Mozart do when he got to Vienna?
Then?
How is he going to patch together a living?
He did it through two,
uh,
two ways.
One,
he was going to,
um,
uh,
give piano,
piano lessons to the aristocracy,
going to give piano lessons to the aristocracy.
And two,
he was going to,
uh,
play the piano in public concerts,
teacher performer.
And as a result of this,
he perfected or contributed greatly to two important jewelers in the history of
music.
Those genres being the piano Sonata.
We've talked about this Denada usually three movements.
Uh,
those he wrote mostly for his pupils.
And then the Piano Concerto,
Mozart wrote 23 original piano concertos,
the piano concerto,
which he wrote principally for himself as a kind of show piece for public
concerts.
And you will be watching in section beginning this evening,
a wonderful video of the performance of the Great d minor piano concerto of
Mozart.
Mozart's piano concertos are much more difficult than,
uh,
he is,
Sonatas.
Uh,
he intended these piano concertos for he himself,
you know,
for him himself,
I guess.
So for him to play,
um,
and he did.
So interestingly enough at this public hall that was located in the casino in
Vienna.
Here's a picture of that casino,
which today is actually the,
it's this building to the right there,
the tallest one.
It's a big building and it had a big public space in it and that's where he
performed a,
it still exists.
That building still exists.
It's the ambassador hotel in downtown and the Noi mark plots there in,
um,
in Vienna.
Uh,
why did Mozart play in a casino?
I was driving down the highway the other day and a saw sign up there,
usher at Mohegan Sun.
My wife thought this might be a po play of,
you know,
but who is Osher raps?
Ours is a musician,
right?
No.
Who's usher?
Come on guys.
Uh,
okay.
Fredrick.
Nice and loud please.
And R and B singer.
But he's playing the casinos because that's where the money is.
Okay.
That's where the money is.
That's where the crowd is.
That's where the money is in.
Mozart was doing this back in the 18th century as well.
The other venue that he played,
I think I've got a slide of this,
Jacob.
Let's take a look at this.
Is the local court theatre,
the board Tejada it wasn't that big.
It was about the size of our own spring hall here.
Morse recital hall inside of Sprague Hall,
seated about,
uh,
80,
excuse me,
800 people.
And for this,
Mozart would have to,
uh,
hire the orchestra.
He would have to compose the music,
he would have to print the tickets,
he would have to sell the tickets out of his own apartment and uh,
he would have to transport his own piano over to this whole,
um,
to,
uh,
provide the instrument for him to play.
Let's take a look at this piano of Mozart.
So here is a piano of Mozart.
It's a very small instrument.
As you can see.
It's compass is only five octaves,
f two F.
Um,
so it,
it,
uh,
and it has only one string per key.
If you go up to the modern grand and actually look at it,
you'll,
you hit middle c actually three strings up there,
they get struck by that hammer.
But in Mozart's piano,
they don't want to be one.
It was much smaller in a number of different ways.
Now,
um,
yeah,
let's take a listen to,
let's listen to a performance on Mozart's piano.
And I emphasize here,
this is not a replica of a piano that,
that Mozart of Mozart's Day,
this is Mozart's own piano.
After he died,
it went to his widow who gave it to,
uh,
the eldest son.
And ultimately it came in back in to Salzburg is today in the volumes house
there in Salzburg.
So this is the real piano.
Uh,
and we're going to hear a performance of the famous Sonata in C Major.
So let's listen to a little bit of Mozart's own piano.
Okay,
stop it there.
Notice that Mozart's piano,
he on the PC was on the dominant there at the end of the first thing,
you know it was,
that's the pitch at which Mozart's piano is tuned and probably pretty close to
what it was tuned in his own day.
So he was writing it in the key of g,
which is here,
but it's they,
it is sounding for our ears there is that higher or lower?
Mozart's the tuning of Mozart's instrument.
Here's what he wrote it for.
Here's what it is.
Sounding higher or lower.
What do you think?
How many say higher?
Raise your right hand.
How many say lower?
Raise your left hand.
Interesting.
Uh,
it's actually lower.
Yeah,
it's down a half a step.
And that was typical.
I think we talked about that before.
The tuning kind of floated around up until really the 20th century when they got
it sorta got fixed at age should be for 40 vibrations per second.
So that's Mozart's own piano.
What did you think about the sound of it?
Any adjectives there?
Somebody tell me something about the sound of Mozart's piano.
Play it,
play the beginning again or are you still there?
And that one.
Okay.
Give me two adjectives about this sound.
Someone give me a shout out.
An adjective.
Sarah Shallow.
Okay.
It doesn't have a lot of resonance.
It does not have,
it's not a big rich sound.
Um,
so the,
the sound that dissipates very quickly because there's not a lot of resonators
around that instrument.
So we'll take shallow.
Give me another adjective.
Uh,
Roger Pungent.
Okay.
Kind of sharp.
There's pungens you said Punchy.
Oh,
I like that.
Even better.
A punchy.
Yes.
Uh,
and I put the word up there Staccato as opposed to Legato.
Mozart's piano does not lend itself to legato lines.
These lines that are tied together.
Think of your ligature,
right?
It's all etymologically related to,
um,
uh,
the word leg ra,
I suppose.
Uh,
so in Legato,
smooth,
connected,
uh,
but that's not the sound that we get.
Mozart's piano.
We get this to Carto as Roger says,
punchy sound.
That's at [inaudible].
So,
uh,
and it's because the hammers are actually made of leather,
kind of hard leather rather than felt in the 19th century,
they put felt on these hammers and it kind of smooths it out a bit.
It makes it less punchy.
So those are a couple of characteristics of Mozart's piano.
It tends to encourage fast staccato playing.
All right,
1791 Mozart dies.
Beethoven had been originally sent to Vienna to study with Mozart,
but then there were family problems.
His mother died back in Bun.
She had to go back and kind of look after the family.
Beethoven.
Mozart was a pianist,
but unfortunately for Beethoven,
his teacher was his father.
So what unscrupulous individual who tried to pass off the rather short Beethoven
as being two years younger than he actually was.
Why would he want to do that?
Well,
oftentimes you get kids,
you know,
the cutoff in produce saw 12 and under soccer or Usta tennis and you're supposed
to,
you can't be 16 before that particular date.
And people would try to sneak over the other side of it.
Uh,
well,
because in terms of the music of Beethoven here,
the father wanted the sun to be the next vendor.
Can't write the next child prodigy,
the next Mozart.
Why?
Because money was to be made in that fashion.
The Mozart family had certainly made enough of it that way,
but eventually Beethoven broke free of this tyrannical environment and bone and
established himself permanently in Vienna.
Think about abundance.
At the very west end of the German speaking lands,
Vienna is off toward the east end of the German speaking lands.
So we went all the way to the other side of it.
But the Vienna,
of course,
was the capitol of the world at that particular particular point.
So here is what Beethoven Young Beethoven looked like when he arrived in Vienna,
permanently about 1797.
I forget it.
We'll,
we'll,
I forgot that slide,
but it doesn't matter.
Let's look at Beethoven here.
Here's young Beethoven,
and here is middle aged Beethoven.
When he is writing things such as,
uh,
the,
um,
uh,
eighth symphony that we,
heard at the Je concert.
So we have Beethoven,
young,
Beethoven,
middle aged,
and Beethoven dead.
Okay.
That's Beethoven's death mask.
The only reason I mentioned this is that it was drawn by Joseph Don [inaudible],
who also was the artist who painted the cover of your textbook.
We'll come back to come back to that just a little bit later.
So when Beethoven,
let's that,
that's too ghoulish let's go back to Beethoven looking a little better there.
I liked that better,
don't you?
So with that vision of Beethoven on the Sh on the screen,
uh,
let's make the point that when he arrived in Vienna,
he sort of astonished the aristocracy by the power of his play,
the aggressive nature of it,
the physicality of it,
the virtuosity of it.
It was much more technical than anything that,
uh,
that moats are had ever created on the piano.
And in part because gradually in this period,
the piano itself was getting bigger and more powerful.
So here is,
let's move on now over dead Beethoven's body here and over to this piano,
which again comes from our own collection of musical instruments.
It's a current IGA piano of about,
um,
I think we know exactly 1799,
uh,
and it was made in Vienna,
two doors down the,
down the street from where that casino was.
That's where the current Iga shop was in,
in,
um,
in Vienna.
So this is the kind of instrument that Beethoven would've played when he first
arrived in,
uh,
Vienna.
Uh,
it's a little bit bigger.
It's got a few more keys added to it.
Uh,
then in 1870 18,
17,
Beethoven,
uh,
well let me,
let's move to the next slide.
I want to show this to you just for a moment.
This does this look like something from the early 19th century picture of
Beethoven,
actually not,
it created in the 1920s,
not 1820s,
but 1920s.
It's a fanciful representation of Beethoven and his musical study there with
papers all around,
you see the ear trumpets on either side is growing death.
You see his bowl of coffee or porridge or whatever on the keyboard.
I'm interested here,
particularly in the piano,
w because w what do we have back there coming out of the piano?
A lot of broken streams.
Okay.
Uh,
and that's kind of important because when he played,
um,
he would frequently break strings here.
Let's move on to the next slide.
It's also something of a fanciful representation of Beethoven's room with the
idea of the moonlight in the moonlight sonata behind it.
But it's a in contains as a piano.
I'm an illustration of a Broadwood piano.
In 1817,
the maker Broadwood gave Beethoven a free instrument,
Gay Beethoven,
a free instrument.
Um,
why would somebody do that?
Aren't these pianos expensive?
Let's go on to,
I think I have a shot of another,
uh,
another one.
This is not fanciful.
This is Beethoven's actual instrument.
Uh,
it is preserved today.
It was purchased after Beethoven's death by Franz Liszt,
the famous pianist,
and taken to ultimately to Budapest.
And you can go into,
I did this two summers ago.
You can go into the national museum there in,
in Budapest,
and it's actually an pest and see this particular instrument still.
So it's still survived.
And as you can see,
it's getting bigger and more powerful.
But why would this maker,
English maker Broadwood give Beethoven a free instrument?
These are expensive.
What?
Nice and loud.
Probably what?
Publicity.
Yeah.
A celebrity endorsement.
Right?
Why does tiger woods drive a Buick?
Do you think he really wants to drive a Buick.
Okay.
Uh,
but nonetheless from TV commercials,
he's seen driving a Buick,
a celebrity endorsement.
And we'll be talking a little more about that.
So this is Beethoven's Beethoven's Broadwood here.
80 18,
17 still existing today.
Let's listen to a little bit of it.
We can make recordings,
peep specialists are allowed to make recordings on.
Yeah.
So here is Beethoven instrument.
Just a little bit of out of a piece of this period by Beethoven.
Okay.
Maybe we'll pause it there.
So do you like that sandwich?
You like to have had that piano in your house?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
A lot of you are shaking your heads.
It sounds slightly out of tune to me.
Um,
and I think maybe the reason is that author was Beethoven's piano.
There are two strings per note.
It's really hard to get two strings exactly in tune.
One the string.
It's what it is.
Three strings,
you'll get the kind of a homogenization of sound,
two strings.
It's a bit more difficult.
I think it's the same thing with singers,
oddly too,
wouldn't you seen seen with two people?
Uh,
it's a little more difficult to tune up one or three.
It's not not an issue.
So it does have this slightly out of tune a sound to it.
But nonetheless,
that is Beethoven's Broadwood piano.
Uh,
what did Beethoven right for the piano?
Well,
32 piano sonatas,
32 piano sonatas and five piano concertos.
Most famous of which,
uh,
and I put this on your member.
I gave you the essential Beethoven sheet a couple of weeks ago,
the most important of these piano concertos as they're so called emperor
concerto.
So we have the emperor quartet by Haydn,
the emperor concerto by Beethoven.
So Beethoven wrote the five piano concertos,
32 piano sonatas,
and these piano sonatas,
we're not so much like Mozart's,
uh,
teaching pieces.
These were,
um,
virtuosic pieces for Beethoven himself to play.
Uh,
how well did he play them while you would think that he would play them?
Absolutely.
Superbly,
but that,
uh,
contemporaries commented that his plane was kind of messy.
Here's what one of them said.
Quote,
his plane is not clean.
He has much fire,
but he pounds a bit too much.
He overcomes diabolical difficulties,
but he does not do so neatly.
Maybe,
possibly,
why might Beethoven have trouble as a performer here in the early 18 hundreds?
That was Beethoven's issue.
Uh,
Caroline,
he was going deaf.
Sophie pounded a bit too much.
Perhaps it's understandable,
but here's the kind of sound perhaps.
Oh,
Lordy.
Um,
here's the kind of sound that,
that,
uh,
the comment or might have had in mind,
Beethoven pounding,
exaggerating a little bit.
Do you get across that that I did two points.
I guess.
One,
what the piano could do for you,
these extreme dynamics and to perhaps Beethoven because of his growing deafness
was pounding a,
a bit too much,
uh,
after Beethoven piano has only continued to get larger and more powerful.
Let's take a look at some of these,
uh,
later.
Uh,
instruments we're moving on now to a graph.
Piano graph was another maker who gave Beethoven an instrument.
Uh,
this,
uh,
comes,
my own shot from the collection of historical musical instruments in Vienna,
a itself.
As time goes on here,
what we find is that in order as this instrument gets bigger and we want a
bigger sound board soundboard,
that thing underneath,
that's the main resonator.
Okay.
Uh,
we need a bigger soundboard and as this thing gets bigger and we want to put
more tension on the strings to really pounds or they don't break them or they
don't come loose,
we need some kind of iron support.
So first they started putting pieces of iron and then all the motley,
an entire frame of bed of iron cast iron underneath that thing for that
soundboard to resting.
Then we need the,
at the other end,
we need a pin block.
Uh,
and that pin block has to be very secure because that's where the pins that
anchor the strings are going to be.
Most of the problems,
if you're,
if you think you've got a deal on the piano sometime check European block
because you probably don't,
uh,
it probably has cracks in it.
And then you go to tighten that.
Things could get your instrument tune the next day,
it's back out of tune because that pin block is not holding a,
so you have to have a very secure pin block.
You have to have a big resonator,
and in order for that to be helped along that needed the cast iron frame
underneath,
all of these things allow for a bigger,
more powerful instrument,
uh,
to be put into play.
So this is a graph,
as I say,
from the collection in Vienna.
Uh,
the,
the range of the instrument is getting bigger.
The sound of the instrument is getting bigger.
Let's go on to the next slide here.
Here's young Franz Schubert about your age,
young Franz Schubert writing the kinds of pieces that we used in the review
section,
for example.
And here's the piano that he was playing,
also a graft instrument in the Schubert Museum there,
uh,
in,
in Vienna.
The graft instrument was also given not only to Schubert and to Beethoven,
but also to Franz Liszt.
Uh,
let's take a look at this.
um,
another graph.
Let's move on to this.
This,
of course is what,
where have you seen this before?
Cover the textbook.
What is this?
This is a marketing tool.
Did these people that included George,
saw,
uh,
Alexander Dumas,
pair Victor Hugo Rossini,
uh,
Paganini.
Did they ever come together and pose for this?
No,
they were in completely different cities.
This is a,
this is a marketing thing.
I was looking at a Brooks brothers thing.
It seemed to,
that seemed to be shot in Princeton.
But if you look carefully,
it had all of these brown leaves on the thing and the people had been patched in
there and,
uh,
the trees around the thing,
they're all in bloom.
I mean,
this is,
this is a hodgepodge.
Well,
this is a hodgepodge too.
Um,
but it's kind of an interesting one because it tells us a little bit about what
the 19th century thought of Beethoven.
Let's go to this last slide here.
So here's Franz Liszt,
the famous Franz lists playing the piano.
He has the historian Marida Google his,
uh,
at his knees there and a typical 19th century sublatory position for women.
And up at the top,
who do we have the bust of Beethoven in Olympian Height,
sort of looking down over the proceeding blessing list and most importantly
blessing the graft piano.
Well,
Liz did a play a graft,
a piano.
Um,
let's listen to,
and we're going to have a slide here,
France list.
Let's go onto the next slide.
Oh No.
Well there's one other one other composer I should mention that's a wonderful
composer.
I don't have time to do,
do anything really with him and in this course,
but he's one of my favorite Frederic Chopin,
Chopin playing a PR play,
l a piano.
And we have over at our collection of play off right?
Not his piano,
but right from the period that he was,
he was playing a,
and let's go on now.
It should be the portrait of,
Ah,
I got them out of order.
Dot.
All right,
let's go into the portrait of list here.
Portrait of list here is Franz list.
Uh,
and let's go back one now.
And here is an air rod piano.
That list played.
Uh,
he actually,
it's actually in the collection of Buckingham Palace.
Um,
but when list went there and played for the Queen for Queen Victoria,
uh,
he played on this particular era instrument.
So it looks very much like a,
uh,
like a modern instrument.
Let's hear just a little bit of lists.
Music.
You have it as a CD for track one.
It's a transcendental etude sort of hugely difficult technical study by Franz
Liszt.
Let's listen to just a bit of lists.
Plane.
Oh,
so this is called a study.
Um,
there's some irony here.
It's called a study in order to you when you play this piece and you get better.
Okay.
Now how good would you have to be to begin with to play this piece?
Holy Schmoley.
I mean,
this is a really difficult,
technically,
Dan,
have you ever played a list transcendental etude oh,
we had,
or we should have gotten into playlists,
transcendental etudes,
kind of the top of the line.
My guess is enlist day there,
probably six or six or seven people,
all of Europe that could actually play these studies that were designed to get
you to be a more proficient pianists.
You were kind of out of the game before the game even began an odd way.
Um,
so,
um,
this is lists [inaudible] piano.
Um,
I want to show just a couple more slides and then we'll introduce our guests.
Uh,
and we've seen the portrait of list.
I was struck when,
uh,
at the list museum in Budapest that when you walk in there and you see that list
played in his home,
and there it is,
it's a big instrument with two pedals down there.
Um,
it's a Chickering instrument and you know where that instrument was made in
Boston.
So Boston was a major in New York also here in 1862.
1870 is major manufacturing company and they shipped one all the way to
Budapest,
a four,
four list,
uh,
to play.
Um,
and,
uh,
find,
find piano indeed a couple more.
And then we're going to stop.
Uh,
and of course when Liz died,
there were particular,
not so much interested in doing a death mask of his face,
but one of his hand because he was thought to have a very unusual sort of
webbing between his fingers that allowed him to stretch in ways that other
pianists couldn't.
A few more.
And then as I say,
we'll stop.
This is an interesting piano.
Um,
list.
Father in law was Ricard Wagner.
You can read about all about this.
And the textbook list fog of there in law was Rickard Wagner and Wagner,
uh,
composed at the piano.
Mozart generally didn't,
but Wagner did a,
and this is the instrument that was involved at the end portion of the composing
of his Opera Tristan.
And we heard Tris,
parts of Tristan,
right?
We heard that.
We heard the Lebus towed out of Tristan.
So it may have been on this very instrument that,
that Wagner,
uh,
composed part of that music.
Whereas this instrument today,
right down the street,
it's in that same collection of historical musical instruments.
This is what we call the Wagner piano over there and Hillhouse avenue.
So pop in some data,
17 Hillhouse avenue book,
the second floor,
and you can see all these historic instruments.
It's the greatest collection of keyboard instruments in the entire western
hemisphere right here.
And it's virtually unknown.
So that's Wagner is pan.
What's of interest is to see how those lines are going straight out to the back.
Um,
there,
there's simply braces,
helping,
helping the soundboard there,
uh,
and the strings are running at right angles,
to,
uh,
the,
the line of the keyboard.
Um,
but things didn't stay that way interestingly enough because as time went on,
there was a German manufacturer.
This is actually a Bechstein.
There was a,
another German manufacturer,
however,
with the name of Stein vague,
who immigrated to the United States and set up in New York City.
And of course that shine vague became what Steinway Steinway piano manufacturers
of New York City.
Uh,
and they instituted a couple of things,
but most importantly they instituted this idea of cross stringing where instead
of having the bass strings run out in a straight line,
they took them and run,
run them up over.
And next time you're at a grand piano,
maybe come up afterwards today,
look at the base strings they run up over the other strings.
What this gives is a much more homogenous kind of sound.
It's a much more homophonic instrument.
Ironically,
the Wagner piano,
when you play it is very clear.
You don't get this kind of wash of sounds because the,
because the strings are,
as you can see,
a little bit more separated.
And here,
this may be our last slide,
is what we end up with at the piano,
a sort of gilded Steinway from the gilded age.
This is actually up in the Clark Museum,
Williamstown,
Massachusetts,
but it is,
it is a Steinway piano.
And you can see on it three pedals,
and this is my last point.
Uh,
initially all the panels up into the Steinway there,
you saw just two pedals underneath.
And these are the two we're going to talk about today.
The right most pedal is called the sustaining pedal.
Play that and um,
uh,
the sound goes away because they're our dampers.
They're pieces of felt up on top of the string.
If I can lift all those pieces of felt,
those dampers just by pushing that pedal down.
And then I get
the dampers are now up.
So we call this the sustaining pedal or the damper pedal sustaining pedal more
often.
And the other one is the one all the way to the left.
And if you can,
what's happening here?
Aja,
look at the keyboard here,
if you will.
What's happening?
Can you see what's happening to the keyboard as I push that left pedal?
Chris?
Daniel.
Yeah,
it's wiggling.
It's going this way.
What's happening is the groups of units of three strings are all sliding so that
when you hit them that way,
you're now,
instead of hitting three strings,
you're hitting only two strings.
It makes the sound softer by shifting the whole keyboard and hammer mechanism.
So only two strings are engaged instead of three.
And that makes the sound a lot more quiet.
All right.
Uh,
that does it for the,
um,
uh,
the,
specifics of today.
Let's introduce our guests.
So Dan,
come on up please.
Uh,
Daniel Schlosberg junior year college.
What college is a Pearson.
Daniel.
Yeah,
he's in Pearson.
Uh,
how many of you know Daniel then?
Brandford oh,
sorry.
I'm sorry.
That's right.
I guess that was was in Branford.
Um,
I heard a recital of him and Branford.
so Dan is a junior now.
He's a music major.
Right?
You're a music major and double majors or anything like that or,
nope.
Okay.
Sometimes,
you know,
Ken shows out there doing microbiology and music,
but um,
but Dan is also a composer.
Right.
Dan does a lot of composing,
so he's really into music and the CEO.
Jude,
do you do any conducting a little,
a little bit of conducting?
Um,
and maybe at the end of the semester be fun when we get to modern music to have
a do a piece by Dan bringing a piece by Dan.
We could have him come back as guest to guest composer.
Uh,
so how long have you been playing piano?
all right.
Okay.
First grade,
six,
seven,
something like that.
Um,
uh,
are your parents musical?
Not at all.
Oh,
no.
That's kind of musical.
Right?
But they're,
so they're not professional musicians.
Um,
and,
uh,
any relatives a in music at all?
Not really.
Uh,
so,
um,
and,
and I hate to embarrass people.
This is something that fascinates me.
You are ear.
Um,
I,
it's,
I always think it's,
you've got to have a really good year to be able to do what you do.
How good is your ear?
Presumably you don't have absent pill?
No.
Okay.
So if we played something for you and told you what the first note is,
you would get the notes they're asked
the piano.
Definitely.
Oh really?
How interesting.
So you do have absolute pitch for,
and I think this is true that some brains are wired for absolute pitch with
particular instruments.
I get pretty close on the trumpet because it was in the fourth grade.
I had to play in a band kind of thing,
play the trumpet.
Um,
so if at a young age you get locked into some instruments and those particular
pitches can stick,
stick with you.
That's interesting.
So almost absolute absolute pitch here.
So that's one thing I wanted to ask you about because if you have a sense of
pitch and if you hear,
you know,
if you know that and playing a piece,
if I go out there,
I mean,
what happens when somebody plays a piece of music?
Lots of things are going on.
Why do I,
Craig have memory lapses when Dan probably doesn't have memory lapses because he
probably has a better ear.
He can remember there's more.
He can stream it there and he knows,
he hears that inside of his head and he knows,
oh,
that's probably an a.
And if I want that sense,
I know to go to that particular spot,
I'm not sure what the sound is in my head.
And they assured don't know quickly,
instantaneously where that thing is.
And this stuff is going by blazingly fast.
So your money's got to be wired for it to begin with.
I think it's a huge benefit to have a really good ear,
even if you are a pianist.
Uh,
another question,
do you ever get nervous when you play dead all the time?
Really?
Uh,
think about that.
Nerves and performers.
Jacob,
do you ever get nervous when you play?
Uh,
you take drugs,
Jacob
recreationally,
pharmacologically,
um,
actually musicians,
anybody ever heard of this?
Musicians do take drugs for this,
the Beta blockers to kind of relax them to lower their heart rate.
French horn players.
I have friends,
professional French,
Horn player,
uh,
justice to kind of get you to settle a little bit because if you play these
instruments and it's just a question of fraction of an incident near like this,
my God,
a string player,
it's a catastrophe and then things start going downhill.
Uh,
so these are the kinds of of mind games I think that performers have to have to
engage.
So do you take lessons here?
Dan,
is the school of music you studying with anybody there?
Okay.
Um,
he is one of the,
the artists teachers over at the,
uh,
school of,
of music.
Do you get any time to practice?
Is a busy place?
Hardly no time,
no time to practice.
That's,
that's the great dilemma for you.
A really good performers,
you know,
there's just no time to,
uh,
to practice.
What do you want to do?
What do you think you want to do with this music business?
[inaudible] so how are you going to connect the dots?
How you going to get from Dan here?
Point A to Dan here 10 years from now?
How do you plan to do that?
Uh,
Grad school,
probably Grad school.
Yeah,
you got it.
For better,
for worse,
you got to get the diploma in all the certificates as I can do this.
You don't mean may or may not make it any better,
but you sort of have to get it to get the menu may make you worse.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I sort of have to get it to get the Gig.
Uh,
okay.
So let's talk about this.
Talk a little bit about this Beethoven Sonata we've got here.
Um,
it's an interesting,
it's an interesting piece,
uh,
because it's so short in a way.
Okay.
Uh Huh.
So 10 minutes.
Uh,
and um,
it,
when you went to the,
how many of you went to the JDE makeup concert?
Okay.
Remember that eight symphony and,
and uh,
how,
how quickly that went through Sonata Allegro form.
There was a period with Beethoven,
uh,
about 18,
10 or so.
We started writing very small things again after the fifth and sixth symphonies
and then they sort of pull back and wrote kind of almost neoclassical things.
And then at the end of his life really expanded out into the realm of the
cosmos.
So this is a kind of pulling back here.
Um,
what's hard in this piece,
Dan?
What,
what,
what
really have to best everything into each whips on Basal Insulin,
a broader scale,
the phrases and the musical ideas of soap next that you really have to focus and
make appropriate contracts quickly.
Okay.
Um,
technically is this the most difficult piece that you have ever played?
Uh,
from a sheer here?
Okay.
Yeah.
Well we get,
we have another one.
We have another one.
In other words,
this is not a Dazzler,
this is not a das or we've saved a bit of a Dazzler for,
for the end of this cause I did want to show you how well this young man plays.
Um,
so let's just listen to the Beethoven.
Uh,
then do you want to do,
um,
I beg your pardon?
Yeah,
let's not,
let's not do it.
We're going to get,
let the cat out of the bag here.
He's not going to repeat the exposition.
That's awesome.
Right?
Actually,
if you look at the score,
Beethoven,
one of the development and the recap also repeated,
but I think in order to get the next more technically demanding piece and we're
just going,
then it's kind of have to do it just without repeats.
I don't mean to upstage him here,
but I'm just going to have to sort of teach as we do this.
It can't just be a concert,
so I'm just going to discretely point where we are in the form.
Okay.
[inaudible]
uh,
okay.
Wonderful piece.
Again,
Beethoven sort of pulling in just a bit there and a wonderful performance.
Um,
I think we have time now for the second piece,
which is by the composer Scarlatti.
Uh,
in the Baroque period.
Hendel,
Buck Scarlatti.
We're all composing in the same period,
all composing in same period.
A all born in 1685.
Uh,
this piece is a sonata by Scarlatti.
It's in one movement.
It goes by rather quickly.
Shall we take,
maybe we should skip repeats here too,
if,
if that,
if that's okay.
So it has a binary form.
We have an a section and then a B section,
and then both of those binaries are going to come back again.
I'll,
I'll sort of,
no,
I won't do that.
It's just in the way,
but the,
a section has lots of this kind of Spanish quick sound and the B section,
you'll hear a rising sequence coming up out of the base.
Yeah.
Hm.
Okay.
Hello.
Thank you very much.
Wonderful.
Thank you.
Okay.
That's it for today.
See you soon.
Section.
Starting tonight.